vocab ready and action
if you're listening to this on your
phone you might want to hide it before
James Cameron sees bad things happen to
those on their phone but if you are
brave enough we're looking at all the
coolest secrets from the making of
Avatar number one did you realize
Sigourney Weaver didn't just play a
younger character in the way of water
it's true she already technically was
playing a younger character in the first
movie perhaps you never noticed this
little detail but her Avatar had been
around for 18 years so it looks 18 years
younger than Sigourney or even her human
character Grace Grace
well who'd you expect numbnuts creating
her Avatar was the toughest because her
features did not translate well to the
Avatar design and so the artist tasked
with making her design brought in
pictures of her from the movie Alien
number two let's start at the end the
end that never was that is the original
ending of Avatar was going to see a
pregnant natiri we are kind of glad they
didn't end it the cliche way not gonna
lie the movie was already leaning on a
ton of them ones that had already gone
out of style in the 90s so it's for the
best the forest will heal so the hearts
of the people number three he's coming
supposedly if your cell phone went off
James Cameron would nail gun them to a
wall he did that with like 20 apparently
right above the exit sign let that be a
reminder to everyone to turn it off in
theaters when the way of water comes out
number four where do you even begin when
forming a language Our Guest is the
little words like the please
an entire language was created for the
navi from scratch by linguist Dr Paul R
frommer what were we going to establish
and then how was everyone else going to
meet that Criterion he was hired to
develop a language that would be easy
for actors to pronounce that didn't
resemble any existing language he
created about 1 000 words
in charge of creating the accent for the
navi in English since she had to speak
it the most Sam Worthington said it was
easier for him an Australian to master
the navi language than the American
accent these guys were just going off
number five a wide range of training was
necessary to get the actors militarized
and then acclimated to Nature Sam
Worthington who plays Jake actually had
to do military boot camp to bring him
closer to his character he had to learn
to use multiple different weapons so
someone came down and showed him what
it's like to hold a gun and all the
other things that would be associated
with being a marine while Zoe had to
move completely unhumanlike right down
to working with her bow with her elbow
bent backwards so we wanted them to have
more of a animal kind of a movement
number six where did Jurassic Park rip
off all its Dino noises from the real
thing but there is a banshee Lane which
makes all kinds of different sounds and
those sounds mean different things most
of the sounds the animals make on
Pandora are recycled noises from the
Jurassic Park franchise
while the yipping and cackling sounds
made by the Viper wolves were real
spotted hyena calls
number seven they could have bummed a
smoke off of literally anybody why rely
on Tech just like almost everything else
in this movie Grace Augustine's
cigarette is CGI honestly we didn't see
that one coming number eight not that
kind of cast Jake's atrophied legs were
Prosthetics cast from the legs of a
paraplegic man with roughly the same
bone structure as Sam Sam worthington's
real legs were tucked into the
wheelchair and digitally removed in
post-production number nine we feel the
navi should also have six limbs all the
Pandora animals have six limbs it wasn't
that simple to just add two extra legs
to an earth horse though they had to
reimagine the anatomy of the characters
too they all moved like ants their front
four legs moved together but the back
two were separate the multiple breathing
orifices were inspired by air intakes on
the sides of sports cars we guess you
can get your inspiration from anywhere
what's the metaphor what are we trying
to say to the audience with every bone
and sinew that we put into this creature
number 10. make them different but not
so different that they aren't sexy James
Cameron took inspiration for the navi
from his mother who had a dream about a
tall blue woman he drew a picture of it
way back in high school too in designing
natiri one of the challenges was making
her look alien but also human enough
that Jake's attraction to her isn't
super off-putting they went through a
ton of designs I wanted people to say I
want to be one of them number 11. how
many movies can you think of really
pushed advancements as much as Avatar
none Avatar paved the way for Tekken
movies like we know it today the navi
actors had cameras attached to helmets
to capture intimate facial performances
they were able to see simple renderings
of the CGI World while filming the
actual facial capture is too complex to
map onto these characters this movie was
also the first to film using a 3D camera
number 12. when writers write often they
include a character with a personality
similar to their own for James Cameron
that was Dr Grace Augustine Sigourney he
said I teased him because to me I'm
playing Jim Cameron in the movie as this
kind of brilliant approach driven
idealistic perfectionist but that same
somebody has a great heart underneath so
I have to say I was always kind of
channeling him number 13. do you think
the world was ready to handle something
new how do you create music for a world
that doesn't exist the music in Avatar
was a new invention meant to not be
linked in any way to any culture Homer
noted I couldn't go off into some weird
world and present a whole new scale
system or a whole new theme system I had
to try to glue everything together no
matter how dense it is on the screen or
how alien it might be there is a thread
in the music that keeps it grounded for
the audience so they know what is going
on and how to feel number 14. one day
Sam Worthington will release a book
about his experience Sam was living in
his car at the time of his audition the
person who called him in for the
audition told him nothing about the
director or the script he was
disappointed at first thinking it was
another waste of of time Matt Damon and
Jake Gyllenhaal were actually the
Studio's first choices to play Jake but
James Cameron wanted to cast the
relatively unknown Sam I just wanted to
say thank you yeah thank you number 15.
Avatar is pretty ancient at this point
James Cameron promised not to take his
pay as director if Avatar flopped this
was just one reassurance 20th Century
Fox had that they wouldn't lose all
their money he originally planned to
have the film completed for release in
1999 but the technology was just not
Advanced enough to tackle the project in
a way that was financially reasonable
while a lot of people say Avatar is just
Disney's Pocahontas that isn't the full
story James had been developing Avatar
since as far back as the 60s he smooshed
four of his scripts together and even
some early concept art from high school
the first script being xenogenesis about
scientists who try to find a new planet
to live on the second Chrysalis was
about a man in a wheelchair who has all
of his sensory inputs removed so so he
can journey through his own mind the
third mother was about a company who
sets up Minds on other planets the rest
of the elements of the story went to his
movie Alien and the last one wind
Warriors was basically the plot of
Avatar except set on Earth in order to
develop a fully realized world it's easy
to see why you need a team of Highly
skilled and super knowledgeable people
to develop single aspects imagine trying
to come up with the language music
culture creatures and Technology to
capture it all yourself it's an
impossible task unless you've got your
master's degree in literally everything
do you have those million dollar ideas
that are just so big you don't know
where to start let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things